[Musique]
vous avez minute alors laissez-moi vous
plonger dans un récit qui mèle tradition
et excellence culinaire ici dans les
ivelines nous remontons à la fin du 19e
siècle où Victor tasséie un pâtissier
restaurateur de Houdan a créé ce qui
allait devenir un emblème une fierté
locale le pâté de Houdan et aujourd'hui
c'est une tradition qui perdure avec un
concours organisé par la confrériie de
la poule les pâté sont jugés sur des
critères très précis les juges examinent
d'abord l'aspect des pièces entières les
tranches sont ensuite évalué par les
jurés et il y a trois catégories
professionnel apprentis et ouvriers
cette année l'un des lauréat est
formateur de l'école hôtelière ferandi
sont pâté à la forme de la lettre H un
hommage à la ville de Houdan mais aussi
une prouesse technique et gustative ce
concours c'est donc l'occasion de voir
comment l'héritage peut-être réinventé
alors que vous soyez finourmet ou juste
curieux le pâté de Oudan est un
incontournable du
département